we're back with more things you didn't
know about breath of the wild this time
we're jumping a little more into secrets
about how damage works in the game that
you might not have known about so if you
enjoy our series here on gamespot hit
that like button we appreciate it
alrighty here we go
the famed lord of the mountain as many
people know is in honor of the late
satoru iwata and he only shows up on
certain faces of the moon specifically
starting on a phase called the waxing
crescent this isn't a coincidence though
as this is the moon phase that iwata was
born in the waxing crescent phase
people also pointed out in the last
video that quince's dog sari is a
nickname short for satori since he was
found on satori mountain socie is
inadvertently named after satoru iwata
now we gotta keep this precious pup safe
stall enemies will never fall for food
bait because well they obviously have no
stomachs
except for stall horses they can't help
themselves if a horsey treat presents
itself where does it go though
most players think that master sword
beams take durability well they're half
right they do when it's not powered up
when you get the fully upgraded master
sword the beams will take zero
durability otherwise they will consume
durability as normal so yes get an
upgraded asap so you can use those sword
beams without the durability hassle also
the master swords beam has different
properties against trees at close or
farther ranges when it's up close it can
cut down trees easily but loses this
ability after a certain distance did you
know that rock octorocks can throw
boomerangs unfortunately they can't
catch them again
it's a tiny detail but when you jump
attack with a spear off of a mount it's
actually a special animation that is
different from your normal jumping spear
attack
as a guy who's been riding for 11 years
that's me i've got some personal insight
to the master cycle the master cycle was
inspired by agl numa's personal love for
motorcycles but the final design for the
game had to be designed off of a dirt
bike for off-roading as a sport bike
wouldn't quite work in the rough terrain
of breath of the wild the developers
even purchased a dirt bike to ride it
themselves to understand its physics
drifting on it is pretty dramatic
compared to actual dirt bike cornering
but it does have the detail of having
the inside foot off the peg which is
standard practice while cornering on a
dirt bike and link does have decent head
placement while turning as you always
want to look ahead of the turn where you
want to go never in front of your tire
one detail they did omit though is the
master cycle has no gears as you'll
never hear the bike shift out of first
gear
well it is a magical bike after all a
concept idea for the master cycle was to
have it appear from a round device
resembling an ancient core after being
tossed on the floor likely for being a
nuisance to re-summon over and over this
idea was scrapped this gives me some
serious pokemon vibes though
while there have been some decent ways
to sneak into gerudo town without
changing outfits the newer method
involves the active aero smuggling trick
and the new campfire glitch
this lets you walk around scot-free
without getting caught well for at least
a little while
did you know that bouncing an object off
a wall as you throw them makes them go
farther
it can be pretty nifty to get some extra
reach for the jump on the enemy or
completing some puzzles
you can cancel out a wind cleavers air
slash with a lightning rod ball
[Applause]
a recent glitch found allows link to
carry any ingredient around as a
physical liftable object by using the
camera rune then holding an item quickly
dropping it then holding a different
item the dropped item is suspended in
mid-air now you can send shooting stars
back to where they came from
spicy peppers and sunshines create
updrafts when lit but there's a neat
trick involving letting them fall to
make a super updraft
by igniting them midair and letting them
fall stasising the ingredients will make
one super updraft
when you find a korok diving hole no
need to find a specific place to jump
off just bomb yourself and ragdoll into
the hole
[Music]
have you ever wondered what heart
containers are made of well you can
guess based off the sound they make when
you shield surf off of them
they sound pretty metallic to me
did you know that you can parry
backwards
the parry is accurate to the hitbox of
the shield itself not to link so if you
move over just a bit as an attack is
striking you it will miss link and hit
the shield instead now that's taking out
a guardian with style
[Music]
headshots are a great way to take down
enemies and have some hidden multipliers
such as the 10 times multiplier against
enemies on archer towers
but have you ever wondered why
headshotting wildlife always kills
instantly even with the wimpy bow
well that's because the multiplier is
actually times ten
thousand yup you heard me right so even
the weakest bow in the game does a
whopping 40 000 damage with a headshot
so if you ever want to feel good about
yourself use an ancient bow with ancient
armor and a triple attack buff head
shotting an animal will then do 1
million 180 000 damage you'll just never
actually see it now that's a lot of
damage it's fairly well known that most
mining weapons such as iron sledge
hammers and stone crushing weapons have
a bonus multiplier against taluses well
just be careful because nintendo just
straight up forgot to add this
multiplier to the luminous tiles
specifically they completely ignore
mining weapon multipliers so you're
better off with just using the best
weapon you got
did you know that nintendo planned to
have arrow crafting recipes in the game
they originally had these recipes set to
combine normal arrows with precious gems
to get different elements such as with
topaz to make shock arrows rubies to
make fire arrows and sapphires to make
ice arrows cast as most players know
travels about hyrule with his signature
instrument but this instrument isn't an
accordion it's called abandoning while
it's in the same instrument family its
key difference is its use of singular
buttons for notes instead of an
accordion's keys
the gates you walk through up the stairs
in reno village denote which floor
you're on by the number of feathers on
its wings
[Music]
link has multiple small animations for
opening chests such as standing in the
front for opening it normally crouching
in front of it to open it sneakily
standing on its size to kick it
crouching on the side to punch it
and kicking it with no pants on does a
number on his toes
[Music]
sometimes funny things are hidden in
plain sight if you talk to the npc
saguessa during the afternoon and say i
know about elixirs she'll comment about
how creeped out she is by how many twins
there are at this table
wait a second huh now that you mention
it that is weird
[Music]
and that's it what was your favorite
thing you learned this time let us know
in the comments below and if you
continue to enjoy new breath of the wild
videos we have a playlist with tons of
stuff we still make to this day for
everything else gaming keep it here on
gamespot
you